and welcome to hannity on this busy news
friday major developments on multiple
fronts tonight coming up green bay
packers star quarterback aaron rodgers
he is blasting democrats the nfl and the
woke mob over their covet 19 hypocrisy
also senator rand paul he will join us
with more on his latest confrontation
with the disgraced and dishonest dr
anthony fauci and democrats are in
complete disarray on capitol hill
tonight but ultimately really nothing in
the house is going to matter because joe
manchin the senator from west virginia
it looks like he will have the final say
as well as kristen cinema from arizona
but first bad news for the biden
administration and bad news for
americans our economy is now officially
in dire straits you can see it
everywhere inflation is spiking economic
growth is stagnant and the workers
shortage is getting worse in september
38 000 more americans dropped out of the
workforce now over 100 million people in
this country are no longer working a
hundred million people but according to
joe biden thanks to him the economy has
recovered faster fairer and stronger
than anyone could have predicted just
take his word for it take a look
these plans i've implemented i got
through these plans of economic economic
success the economic rescue and and
vaccination plans just both of them have
made the economy the envy of the world
we're the fastest growing major economy
and one creating jobs at a faster pace
than anyone
yet
yes there's you know there's a lot more
to be done
we still have to tackle the costs that
american families are facing
but this recovery is faster stronger and
fairer and wider than almost anyone
could have predicted
no doubt biden has no idea what's
actually going on he is as we have been
telling you now everybody's joining in a
little late but they're finally getting
it that he is weak and frail and joe
biden is a complete cognitive mess so
tonight i have a message for the woke
social justice warriors that are writing
biden's speeches
you can lie your way out of
an economic catastrophe but it's never
going to work in the middle of a trucker
shortage a supply chain crisis biden's
vaccine mandate could cost the trucking
industry alone
over 30 percent of its workforce and
it's not only trucking soon millions of
workers in the private sector the public
sector will be out of jobs as teachers
as nurses you know the people that put
their lives on the line at the worst
moment in the middle of this pandemic
diving on one coveted grenade day after
day after day cops firefighters first
responders blue collar workers you name
it our military add to this the rising
gas prices all caused by joe biden and
that could cause a horrendous period of
what is known as stagflation after the
biden administration cut america's oil
and gas supply after they killed the
keystone xl pipeline after they banned
exploration on federal land the prices
at the pump they have been soaring we
are now paying almost 1.50 more per
gallon for gasoline it's costing more to
heat and cool our homes but we have
rising prices on everything everything
now costs more because it costs more to
manufacture and it costs more to deliver
to the stores that you go to this
morning one cnbc anchor posed a very
reasonable question to biden's energy
secretary this answer and this response
should make your blood boil
because
joe biden was handed
absolutely handed energy independence we
weren't importing oil from saudi arabia
we were a net exporter of oil for the
first time in 75 years because of donald
trump's policies that joe abandoned and
here's their answer to higher gas prices
and higher prices
for everything that you buy
what is the grand home plan to increase
oil production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious
and then she went on to blame opec and
the cartels what's funny about that we
were energy independent instead of
begging opec and getting rejected for
the ninth time we can produce more oil
more gas right here in america it
creates high paying career jobs in the
energy sector it reduces shipping costs
and i'm not sure what's so funny to the
biden administration because the people
that are being hurt the most are
americans that are poor and middle class
they are now being hit with higher
prices on everything but oh what a dumb
idea it's the cartel's fault it's opec's
fault no secretary it's your fault and
it's joe biden's fault but according to
granholm the only way to lower energy
prices is what we're going to beg opec
again to get rejected again because opec
said no not once not twice they keep
saying no and now there's just nothing
the white administration can do
yeah they actually can they can lower
the price of energy by going back to the
policies that worked under donald trump
that would mean energy independence
otherwise it's higher prices for
everybody and by the way you're not
going to be able to spend the money
anyway because our supply chain is so
screwed up also self-induced problems a
big deal according to biden nope he says
no big deal one white house official
snarky
you're just not going to be able to get
the jacket in 15 colors but at least
you'll get a jacket jenn saki calling
the tragedy
calling this the tragedy of the missing
treadmill mayor pete saying oh well if
you don't want to disappoint your kids
at christmas you need to shop for
christmas in october and if not oh well
so too bad
no christmas for your kids this year if
the results of biden's first year in
office tell you anything improving your
life is not a high priority for them the
tragedy of the treadmill really
overreaching far left radical socialism
with a heavy dose of virtue signaling
almost on a daily basis that's way more
important that's why biden's doj is now
floating an idea to pay certain illegal
immigrants people that didn't respect
our law our borders our sovereignty up
to 450
thousand dollars apiece
today in an exchange with our own peter
ducey well biden's deputy spokesperson
provided a classic excuse for this
insane proposal that even joe indicated
the day before he hadn't even heard of
and thought was a dumb idea but now
they're backtracking and say oh it's a
great idea and of course it's always
donald trump's fault
your administration is negotiating cash
payments
for some illegal immigrants who are
separated from family members under the
last administration why give taxpayer
money to people who broke federal law to
get here
you like this question peter we talked
about what we talked about this
yesterday but not to the heart of the
the point which is that these people
broke the law to come here and they are
going to
get
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
taxpayer money but you know i said this
to you yesterday peter one of the things
that we have to remember what why we're
in this place that where we are today is
because we had an administration that
had an inhumane immoral policy